the Smithsonian American Art Museum to
be enshrined within its walls as to be
accorded the status of high art it's the
exalted home of such artistic luminaries
as John Singer Sargent Gilbert Stuart
and now the Super Mario Brothers
this year the Washington establishment
fully embraced Lara Croft the Tomb
Raider Sonic the Hedgehog Leisure Suit
Larry and so many others in a major
exhibition called simply the art of
video games it's a move some feel was
long overdue
you know while it's taken about two and
a half years to create this exhibition
I've been waiting for this my whole life
Chris Bellis eNOS is not only the
curator of the exhibit much of what is
on display comes from his personal
collection perhaps more than anyone on
the planet he knows just how far gaming
is common American culture over the past
few decades this exhibition could not
have happened at any other point in
history than right now and that is an
understatement
this hearing is called to order
less than 20 years ago official
Washington's relationship with video
games was anything but admire in 1993
members of the nascent gaming industry
were hauled before Congress and publicly
scolded for promoting violence sexism
racism and even crimes against humanity
instead of enriching a child's mind
these games teach a child to enjoy
inflicting torture we need to make every
effort to reduce this culture of carnage
and we need to make that effort now
because with interactive technology and
virtual reality these games are going to
become even more sophisticated and
persuasive ever since the first
Nickelodeon open there are people who
are afraid about the impact of popular
culture and try to regulate them right
away
Caryn Stern himer is a sociologist at
the University of Southern California
focuses on pop culture and the moral and
social panics it inevitably produces
with every new form of media there's
typically anxiety about what change it's
going to bring so we had panics about
movies comic books television
heavy metal music rap music this kind of
concern has echoed really throughout not
just decades but centuries and like all
good moral panics before it the video
game hysteria of the 1990s followed
usually when there is a concern about a
particular form of media
there's usually either an activist or a
groundswell of concern that something
has to be done teachers by day parents
by nights we all work so hard to raise
our children to learn proper
problem-solving and to raise them to be
good American citizens and all our
actions are undermined by the moment
they go to the video game and they learn
that the only way to solve a problem the
quickest most efficient way to solve a
problem is kill them off and so it
starts to take on us a feeling of common
sense of course it affects our children
if we lost all common sense of course it
affects our children and it affects our
kids in a very negative way I mean we're
all aware of this incredible outbreak of
gun violence in our countries it is it
responsible our nation's children should
not be told that to be a winner you need
to be a killer politicians sometimes
help initiate this but sometimes quite
frankly they're riding that wave they're
noticing that there's a lot of people
upset about something and they can kind
of look like the superhero who's riding
in to save the day to create new
legislation or to hold a hearing that
seems to solve the problem that everyone
thinks is obviously here I want to thank
you gentlemen so much for bringing this
issue to the public you need to be
applauded maybe just maybe this hearing
maybe just maybe your efforts will be
important in the lives of children and
we'll make improvements in this world I
hope so
usually these bills either died in
Congress which happens a lot or there's
a hearing that's held which gets a lot
of news media attention and kind of is
the dog and pony show that a lot of
politicians are looking for this is the
hand held implement with which you play
the game by shooting it at the screen
and what does this game seem to teach
our kids basically that a gun can solve
any problem yet just as video games
became ever more popular ever more
violent and ever more artists
violent crime started dropping faster
than a barrel in a Donkey Kong game and
with the Phantom Menace contained the
gaming industry continued to grow into
the multi-billion dollar business it's
become and just like film rock music and
comic books before it gaming is now not
just tolerated but actively courted in
Washington from the formation of a new
Congressional Caucus devoted to
electronic entertainment to the
placement of campaign ads on Xbox games
to the entombing of a Commodore 64
behind Plexiglas at the Smithsonian
we're seeing more people in politics who
probably grew up playing video games and
if if the Smithsonian is embracing it
it's probably been a large part of our
culture for some time for the first time
we have gamers raising gamers and I
believe from this point forward you're
going to see a greater more rapid you
know appropriation and acceptance of
video games well as everything from art
to worthwhile pursuit
you